ça s'appelle une initiation un art
majeur devant une initiation pas un art
mineur comme ce que les gones économies
que nous faisons nous mais quelle est
pour le surréalisme qui vous avez rien
de médor une chanson mais si les gars
mais qu'ici à leurs abonnés alors c'est
béart qui te parle
oui mais en quoi est ce que ces mineurs
une chanson sans cui sectionnaire simu
gardner situera que la peinture il n'a
pas besoin d'initiation mais tu as
toujours la chanson cabessut à des
initiations pour la pinte pour les arts
majeurs mais l'architecturé la peinture
et la musique classique et la
littérature et la poésie architecture
qui unissent et quand la poésie s'il te
plaît ne faisons pas de la poésie
non il n'y a pas d'armé mais ce n'est
pas la peine de faire de la chanson dans
ce mineur sinon je ne serais pas là tout
est important même la cuisine c'est là
tu prends du pognon c'est le pauvre
cervelle moi je viens de boer toutes vos
chansons qu'on tirait que ce sont des
choses mineures alors absolument c'est
vrai sauf certaines qui ont frôlé une
omission sur un beau certaines lesquels
est le dieu du jeune melody nelson
sauriol jeu et sur les dernières
chansons de charlotte et de la chanson
d'isabelle adjani zh celle de jean
berges